ああああああああ
こんにちははじめ殺王でよみうりランドの方に遊びに来ているんですけども
のよみうりランドの敷地内に新しいエリアができたということで本日ちょっと遊びに来
ておりますその名もこちら
グッズ版でございまーすこちらのグッズバーニーは
ものと霧に関する15機種のアトラクションがありまして生活に密着した子どもたちが
したし
見やすい自動車食品発車文具のよっての構造から成り立っていますもたくさんの赤楽
さんがあるのでちょっといろいろ楽しんで遊んでいきたいと思いますではいきましょう
見えてきました
こちらですねキャンプツリーサポート一派
ニッスイにスタンで実際です i 警備で無事に着きましたカスタムがレイズでござい
ますここでは主に動作のものづくりを体験できるということでちょっと実際に空母を
造るのかな
フレーズ絶対にやってみましょうせっかく工場になんですけども
サポート企業さんやパートナー企業さんが付いてましてその
各メーカーさんのものづくりを体感できるみたいなん
ああああああ
せていただって
早速組み立てていきましょうと言いたいところなんですけども
そうここは factory 閉めったーと打ってないととても危険です何ちょっと僕
はこの空からはちょっとヘルメットをつけて作業に帰りますとで特別な特徴で
ヘルメット
ずんです実教フラックスたんっ
何ですかこれこれをかぶって作業に入りたいと思います皆早速やっていきましょう
まずはボンネット聖堂からつけていきましょう結構ありますよねあなんかとりあえず色
的にこれがかっこいいからこれにしましょう
きたんじゃないですかこれ次はフロントライト言いましょういや絶対男はこれでしょ
部署によって
絶対声ですよああ
できましたああいうわけで今からね寿司女のようです
つきましたありがとうみなさんでに実際足を運んでやってみてください入って指でやっ
てました次はこちらですね
スピンなのでこれはファッションのファクトリーでございます早速やっていきましょう
抜けていただきます
セボっ
こちらのモニターははい
マイナーから地裁に
ファーストこの呼ぶちゃんとっ
不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不
不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不得手きた
見えていくんちょっと絶対コースターチックなものがありました
はいございます米良さっそく乗っていきましょうよつきませオッズぞ
すごいすごい
いろんなものがありますね
アプラスちゃーす
紅ん
ふっとプップップ頭メイドの時間です
はい
はいあーん
ブラウザ
ジャンプだった
ザーぜなんだやっ
ナンパ
じゃあ終わってしまったああ
1個1
f
pa
albano 子
ほっん
入ってあげて釣った三宝亭共箱そばさがずっとコースターが苦手なのでちょっと厳しい
ものがありましたすごい迫力満点で楽しかったですね皆さんもやってみてください
じゃあ次のアトラクションに行きましょう
た
プードのファクトリーでございます wiki を取るとリー氏いたの入港をテーマに
したファクトリーです中のほうが入っていきましょう
45ファクトリーということで聞いた話っていう自分の iphone が作れる
あんなしょーちー田村市と言っています
こちらの一番ほっに注意しでございまして
男女
嫌ったものよとなりますじゃあとってもリアですかはい出たらめっちゃきっ
を開けちゃいいところです
ねっ遊びですかねっ
ねえええマジですかヤッター形では発足からデザインを作っていくみたいですか
栄養知事いう自覚するどうぞ難しい
今たベラ直しくださっていうかと書きまーすいい感じ兼務させてあげよう
できますどうでしょうかはい見せてくださいはい
大樹さんをイメージしたに4 s 4
ありがとうございまーすって来てありがとう
バーナーが込められますあぁよかっ個別ありがとうございますおい
以後中国でもキャップなどが出てきてちょっと
中3種類の具材入学ら大好きなものを4つお選びください
はいぽてっとグー高いスタッフメロおよびクロソイ
ポテトでをテトラ路もありました3つ
めぐってください結構いろいろ cd があるんではい
あとでアポとあるじゃん最後にもう一つ上だでください
キャベツで空いてるで無事完成しましたーー
すごいなんて俺入ってさっ
相次ぎです次のアトラクションですこちら1回パターのある食感が2位パッドで頑張り
スカイパトロールと飯が美味くてこのアトラクションこのエリア内を
固まるスープ員であるソクさんの司会パティちょんちょん縫う大一に涼しい
r ソックスではいってきますパドローネ
a 5 a 爆ぜた水景色がこのワールド
にゃんん
ずっと3赤瀬たらよかったですでは次って皆そう
プードゥル工程を
ブーバーそ
なぁなぁなく3件
なったいって言うグランツさん家ような
8 a 1
uh
これもとございますやったーーー
雑魚です
ヌー嬉しいですけど
いいえはっはっは
tee
[ __ ]って
ああ次行かなきゃおっしょべ通っ
すべてのん
初早く断ったんです
ここダメみたいですね難しかったけどすごい楽しかったですよねぇー
じゃないですか
he
いうことで何言ったら大丈夫スプラッシュというか
水がポイントかそれじゃないすかね分かんないですけどそれでとっていきましょう
履いて外でこの朝が来そうです私たちが焼きそばが作られる過程における面の曲に
なれるというアトラクション
まずはここで全部わかりますしっかり汚れを下さいっすわー先祖
すごい
よろしく様なさいってきまーキャップ25良い
すごいね一人あげますようわぁ
ああああああ
wh
us work to do
dj
ごめんたマロンぐらいは w ああああ
上が豊かならー
far
ran うわーうわーうわーうわー day 4
ってや感がある
んおおおお
以降めっちゃでけあれまってすぐには燃え方の怒ってるん
はいという意味でなんかすごい水がたくさんかかったけど
カラーする楽しいアトラクションでしたやっとらのフル皇帝とかもなんかよくわかって
すごい楽しかったです
入って上でグッズバナートラクションいろいろ回ってみたんですけども
すごい久しぶりにこういうちょっとテーマパーク月のところにこれで主人的には
楽しかったです
goods bar ですねその普通に遊び音樂舎6
意外にもどうやってものができているかとかものづくりの猫の音皇帝とかが色々分かる
のでただ遊ぶだけでなく勉強にもなりますべき皆さん遊びに来てください
そしてグッドばはですねあの屋内のアトラクションなので雨が降ってても遊ぶことが
できます
goods bar ヘルメットのおかげでいい動画が当たりましたふうに打つば遊び
に来てくださいじゃあな
ん
me
cap